ten new cheetah cubs are making
themselves at home this morning in
Virginia a Smithsonian Research Center
welcomed the unprecedented number of
Cubs at the facility last month
researchers are working to breed more to
preserve the species fewer than 10,000
cheaters are left in the world chip
readers at the Smithsonian's Center in
Front Royal Virginia to see how
caretakers are keeping the animals
healthy good morning
well good morning there are 20 adult
cheetahs at this Smithsonian breeding
facility in the Blue Ridge Mountains of
Virginia that's mom over there these are
her two sons and that's her daughter and
there are 16 other adults and now there
are 10 tiny little Cubs it's an
extraordinary victory for this
vulnerable species and we got to meet
them face-to-face these tiny Cubs are
just three weeks old and steadily
gaining weight their brothers and
sisters born to seven-year-old cheetah
Mitte they sound like they're purring is
that purring no they are actually
growling scrubs are required to reduce
exposure to disease and the human scent
around the cheetah den which would upset
Mitty Adrianne Crozier a biologist with
the Smithsonian is the manager of its
cheetah reproductive and research
program she checks in on the young cubs
and weighs them about twice a week does
this ever get old no it's always fun to
have Cubs the scientists here hope for
at least one cheetah litter a year and
this year they got to 12 Cubs total
while two babies did not survive having
this many cubs born so close together is
a virtual population explosion every day
that they make it through though we just
have a better chance of them surviving
to adulthood cheetahs are listed as
vulnerable and some scientists have been
calling for the fast cat to be moved to
the endangered species list why are they
vulnerable
mostly loss of habitat the areas that
they occupy in Africa have been reduced
dramatically cheetahs have disappeared
from an estimated 76% of their natural
range today they are mostly
in southern Africa especially Namibia
but here in the Virginia mountains
Crozier and her team are doing critical
work to help the species survive I hear
you've been called the cheetah Cupid you
are matchmaker
yes we try to make as many good cheetah
matches as we can every year scientists
refer to the walkway between the adult
cheetah and closures as Lovers Lane
often this is where we will let the
males meet the females for the first
time on the fence so far the Institute
has bred 46 cheetahs in Virginia and
Crozier is hopeful their work will
prevent the world's fastest land animal
from disappearing forever just as having
these two litters in the last few weeks
just gives us huge hope very optimistic
about the populations that we manage
under our care and linking more with the
populations in the last so the cheetah
is here to stay the cheetah is here to
stay as for those 10 Cubs they're not
with us right now because they're with
their mothers in their dens and their
mothers have made very clear it's time
for humans to stay away so what will
happen to those 10 Cubs will some might
stay here at this breeding facility
others will go to other zoos and
breeding facilities around the nation
and one I'm gonna try to sneak out of
here my myself Gayle but please don't
tell anybody I won't tell anybody I
don't know who's cuter chip for those
cheetahs whoa he's a married man I
didn't say one to do anything with it I
just said it was cuter and somebody
wants to Nina in fact can you look at
the menu doesn't mean you need a black
she's my old trainer Nina knows I'm safe
yeah those I'm safe they are thank you
very much cheetahs are adorable very
glad they're they're doing that program
great